what a day for the houston astros as
they have lost five players to the covid
injury list so non baseball related
lansing colors junior on the mount for
the astros a 1.8 0 era and a 1-0 record
in two starts this year 10 innings four
hits six walks 13 strikeouts two outs
made on second
brings up no mar mazzara
mazzara hitting 250 289 on base
percentage two homers
and five rbis had a two run home run in
last night's game
lance brings the hands together that
bright orange glove
that he features 2-2
ground ball right side waiting on a diaz
he has it a step into the outfield and
throws to first in time to get mazara
and in the inning
so mccullers gives up a lead off double
but strands him at second and after a
half inning tigers nothing astros coming
up meanwhile it's michael fulmer on the
mound for the tigers moved back into the
rotation after some injuries he was
rookie of the year in 2016 an all-star
in 2017 michael brantley stands in
hitting 310 in eight games 355 on base
percentage two homers and four rbis for
brantley
right at the second baseman
or into the shift nico goodra and it's a
one two three first inning for michael
fulmer
so nunia is at second scope at first
nobody out here's akil badu
waiting on the 2-2 from the colors on
the way swinging a line drive down the
left field line will it stay fair it is
into the corner rounding third headed
home nunez scope will be held at third a
kill but do with another extra base hit
breaking ball away he stayed on it and
drove it down that left field line rbi
double and a keel badou does it again
jump starts the offense and gives the
tigers a one-nothing lead in the second
he's absolutely mr buggy whip
so second and third none out
it brings up nico goodram infield back
three shifted to the right the 3-2 pitch
and swinging a shot into the shift
correa fields checks that runner at
third scope and throws to first that's a
good swing for nico goodroom but it's
out number one yeah he followed that
ball he tracked it did not try to pull
it that's all you can do is hit the ball
hard just having to hit this to somebody
but good swing jonathan scope be able to
trot home because he was going on
contact so it's two nothing tigers two
outs two in but do still in scoring
position
back to the top of the order and robbie
grossman who doubled his first time up
now grossman waiting in a 2-2 but due at
second two outs two-nothing tigers the
pitch swinging a ground ball and that's
going to get up the middle in the center
field a base hit the tigers will add a
run
robbie grossman is two for two akil badu
crosses home plate
he got it started with the rbi double
and now he makes it three nothing on the
grossman single
here's carlos correa
correa on the ground and a nice dig
from harold castro
one two three second inning for michael
former bases are now loaded
for jamer candelario the one two swing
the line drive base hit into right field
in the score comes scope good room right
behind him and he will score without a
throw over to third goes grossman two
out two run single for jamer candelario
and the tigers now they did five nothing
in the fourth
so two in so far still two men on
five nothing lead for detroit here's
wilson ramos
oh two to ramos delivers a base hit to
right
another run is home as grossman trots in
and the tigers pad their lead to six
so mazara comes to the plate now with
runners on first and second
he's dangerous
big cut fall tipped it into the globe of
jason castro
six nothing tigers here in the fourth
and what a sound doug teeter wants to
come out to
have a word with no mar mazar that swing
that he took that first swing yeah
he went across home plate like that well
dougie wants a little air he's going out
he got it he's coming out how about that
oh my goodness
jacoby jones is going to take mazara's
spot
3-2
and jones will take the walk
and the ninth batter of the inning will
come up now and it's renato nunez
who's 0 for one with a hit by pitch
here's the one two
and that's a number and it's getting by
the pitcher's mount and over to correa
and he gets him
as he throws on the run and saves
further trouble no doubt about it
charging was correa
second and third for the astros two men
in scoring position
for the team leader in rbis kyle tucker
he has 11.
candelario even with the base at third
off the line
good room shades up the middle it's
short first pitch to kyle tucker ground
ball to first diving stop by scope flips
to former for out number three jonathan
scope continues to shine at first and
michael fulmer shuts out the astros
through the first four we head to the
fifth inning in houston two outs and a
runner at first for castro
the 2-1
hit in the air to center and deep going
back jones at the wall looking up see
you later
a two-run home run for jason castro off
the batter's eye
castro's second home run of the year and
it's 6-2 detroit
that almost went over the batter's eye
in center field that was a blast
straight away for castro
two ounces it up to jacoby jones he
inherited a 2-1 count and drew a walk
in the fourth inning when mazzara was
lifted during the at-bat with that left
abdominal strain
2-2 to jones swing and a miss got a
fastball by him inside third strikeout
for belak and he strands a pair
scoreless two and a third innings of
relief for b lack
julie guriel certainly the guy you'd
want at the plate right now with the way
he's been swinging it doubled back in
the fourth inning
3-1
hit up the middle and in the center
that's a base hit diaz around third and
coming home no throw home by jones diaz
scores guriel with an rbi it's six to
three tigers
and now it's abraham toro to the plate
as the tying run
3-2
sent to deep center jones is drifting
back
and buck farmer gets that final out in
the six the stressful six comes to an
end abraham toro battled nine pitches
deep fly ball but it's out number three
just a run for the astros in the sixth
we head to the seventh inning tigers
still on top by three six three after
six
ronnie dawson the batter new pitcher is
alex lang
dawson has his first major league hit
ronnie dawson a little
fist pump as he heads down the line and
slaps his hands together ronnie dawson
congratulations his first major league
hit leading off the seventh inning with
a clean single left yeah get that
baseball
congratulations ronnie dawson and
welcome to the club
so the bases are loaded tying runs are
on and abraham toro will come to the
plate as the go-ahead run
soto sets the 1-1 swinging a ground ball
to short goodrem down to second one
castro relay to first and soto gets the
six for three inning ending double play
that's the way that's the way you're
drawing up baby
and it brings up renato nunez who is
over three tonight hit by a pitch and
scored in the second
here's the 0-1
ground ball left side diving to his left
toro stops it gets to his feet throws a
one hopper to first guriel able to grab
it and the inning is over excellent play
by toro on the dive
good news for the astros as they have
their hottest hitter at the plate julie
guriel
3-2 from garcia outside ball four
through a slider bases loaded walk
dawson scores at six to four tigers
and now it's kyle tucker at the plate
tying run is in scoring position that
straw at second the go-ahead run
is guriel at first the winning run
another 02.
he's got him looking
brian garcia comes on to notch his sixth
career save he inherits a bases loaded
jam in the bottom of the ninth inning
walks in one but strikes out tucker with
a potential tying run at second and the
tigers
sweep the astros in houston